[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUTTY KAWAHARA: Hello, everyone.
This session is to
explain how Dragon Quest
Walk, a game currently
very popular in Japan,
handles millions
of players and how
Cloud Spanner is
essential to managing
high volumes of requests.
My name is Yutty, customer
engineer from Google Cloud,
working with gaming
industry companies in Japan.
Today, I'm with Taka, who
is an engineer from Colopl.
The most difficult part
of launching a new game
is unpredictability.
Once the game gets
popular, the server
often receives massive
requests in the short-term.
Compute is very easy to scale.
If you need more resources,
you simply add more servers.
But the database
often [? begins ?]
a bottleneck because
legacy databases like MySQL
are not designed to
scale horizontally.
So when the database
is overloaded,
this is what happens.
For game players, I think this
is the most frustrating error
message.
If you are a loyal player,
maybe it's not a big deal.
But if you are logging
in for the first time,
it may be your last time.
Very few games can overcome
this type of error at launch.
So how do game companies have
the database scaling program?
Well, in general, gaming
company need [INAUDIBLE]..
And they use a technique
called sharding,
which creates a single
database on different servers.
For example,
sharding can be done
by players, by geolocations,
or by gaming platforms.
This is a broad generalization.
Sharding might be a solution
but can lead to hidden costs,
as you can see in this iceberg.
First, maintenance
costs-- for example,
if single database server
can handle 10,000 players,
that means you need 100 servers
for every million players.
I think no one wants to
manage hundreds of servers.
Second, upgradability--
players from all over the world
will play at all
times of the day.
Therefore, the database
has to function 24/7.
It is impossible to find hour
of big maintenance window that
accommodates everyone.
[? About ?] downtime,
traditional relational
databases offer
high availability
using a failover mechanism.
This means if the database
server fails, it will recover.
But it generates downtime.
Today, Google Cloud
offers many types
of database, including
Firestore, Cloud SQL,
and third-party
partner solutions,
which are designed for
various customer needs.
Dragon Quest Walk has chosen
Cloud Spanner as their database
since it is the ideal, fully
managed, scalable database.
Cloud Spanner combines the
benefit of relational database
structure with nonrelational
horizontal scale, which
means Spanner is [INAUDIBLE].
Spanner also provides
horizontal scale in/scale out.
It is fully managed and
has no planned downtime.
In addition, Spanner can
provide up to [? 99.999% ?] SLA.
As I mentioned earlier,
traditional database
have big hidden costs.
By deploying your
game on Cloud Spanner,
you can [? draw ?] much
[INAUDIBLE] these hidden costs.
Spanner can scale out with
one click and upgrades
automatically without downtime.
Data is replicated
across zones, which
result in high availability.
But how does this
translate into numbers?
When Enterprise Strategy Group,
which is a research firm,
did a three-year TCO analysis
for Spanner against us
other traditional
and cloud databases,
they found that you can
save 37% of the cost,
compared to other cloud
solution, and 78% of cost,
compared to other
on-premise solution.
The savings mainly come from
hardware investment, as well as
many administrative
tasks that you
need to spend on to make
sure your database stays up
and running.
Now, let's hear from
our customer, Colopl,
and how they adopted Cloud
Spanner in their game,
Dragon Quest Walk.
TAKAYASU OYAMA: Hi.
My name is Taka, and
I'm a software developer
for a Japanese game
company called Colopl.
I will take over
from here and briefly
talk about how we use Cloud
Spanner in Dragon Quest Walk.
Before I go into
the details, allow
me to do a brief
introduction about the game.
The game is called
Dragon Quest Walk,
and it was developed by us
and published by Square Enix.
The game is part of a
long-running Dragon Quest
series owned by Square Enix.
So here are some
screenshots of what
the actual game looks like.
The game is a merge
between location-based AR
and a traditional,
turn-based JRPG.
The game is for mobile,
and it's available in Japan
for Android and iOS.
So here are some numbers to give
you an insight of how much data
we process every day
with Cloud Spanner.
So we released this game back
in September of last year.
And I can't say
the exact numbers,
but we had a lot of users
register on the first day.
What I can tell you is that we
had over 5 million downloads
on the first week.
Currently, we
still have millions
of monthly active users,
and we process thousands
of queries per second
across hundreds of Spanner
nodes every day.
Here's the agenda
for what I'm going
to be talking about today.
First, I'll start by talking
about why we chose Spanner.
Then, I will talk about
how we integrated Spanner
into our development.
After that, I will talk
about some of the challenges
we faced with Spanner.
So here are some
of the reasons why
we chose Spanner for this game,
starting with the first one
on the list, scaling in and out.
So we used to use a self-managed
MySQL to handle our user data,
and we scaled it by splitting
data into horizontal shards.
In our past titles, this
worked well for us at first.
But when the numbers
of shards start
to grow into double digits, we
started to notice some problems
with this approach.
The problem arose whenever
we wanted to scale.
When we scaled these
databases in or out,
we had to scale
manually and we had
to scale once every few months.
We would scale out to handle
the high traffic whenever
we released a new
feature or whenever
we did a seasonal
event, and then, we
would scale in to save costs
once the hype cooled down
and the traffic eased.
Preparing and
executing these tasks
took hours and sometimes
days, depending on the scale,
and it was stressful
and time-consuming.
By switching to Spanner, we were
able to do this with one click
and scaling would complete
within a few minutes.
So that was reason number one.
So the second reason
why we chose Spanner
was for stability.
In our previous titles,
as I've mentioned earlier,
we used a self-managed
MySQL, and we
used to get unexpected
crashes at least
once a month, mostly
due to host errors.
With Spanner,
everything is managed
and all the problems are
handled in the background.
Now, we've been running this
game for over six months now,
and we haven't had any major
downtimes, just minor ones,
and it wasn't Spanner's
fault. So I could confidently
say stability has been good.
So that was reason number two.
The third reason
we chose Spanner
was so we could write a more
readable and maintainable code.
Previously, when we had to write
code for sharded databases,
our code had to be
infrastructure-aware,
which made it hard
to read and maintain.
One example of this
would be something
like distributed
transactions, where
you have to make transactions
across different shards.
This was hard to
understand, and it
was even harder to debug,
especially for the parts
where we had to roll back.
Then, there are things like
replication delays, where
data retrieved from the replica
might not be up-to-date,
so we had to be careful about
where we read our data from.
After switching to
Spanner, we were
able to make inserts,
updates, and deletes
in a single transaction,
and replication delay
became a non-issue because
consistency is guaranteed.
Now, I would like to talk
about how we integrated Spanner
into our development.
When we first decided
to use Spanner,
we had the feeling it was
going to be a bumpy ride,
since no one at the company
had any experience with it
and there was very
little information
available online at the time.
So we did some
preparations to make sure
that the transition
from MySQL to Spanner
would be smooth and
painless as possible.
So how did we do this?
Well, first, we created
a small, dedicated team.
And by team, I mean
me and my colleague.
So me and my colleague
perform some basic benchmarks
to check the performance.
And once we confirm that
the performance was good,
we put in some extra
effort to making
a dedicated driver
for a PHP framework
we were using called Laravel.
Doing so allowed us to use
pre-existing [? ORM, ?] which,
in turn, allowed us to
reuse existing libraries
we were using for
existing games.
By the way, we've uploaded
the driver we wrote on GitHub,
so please take a look at
it if you're interested.
So once the driver was
written, we tested the driver
by taking an existing game and
replacing the MySQL driver that
was used with a Spanner driver.
This worked well
because we get to see
how it performs
on real scenarios
and allowed us to weed
out bugs we couldn't
catch with our automated tests.
Doing this also helped us get
familiar with the database much
quicker than trying to apply
it to a game from scratch.
After all that was done,
we integrated Spanner
into the main game
development cycle.
By doing these
preparations, we were
able to fully integrate
Spanner into our game
in about two weeks.
Now I'll talk about
some of the challenges
we faced with Spanner
and also talk about how
we overcame those challenges.
First one on the
list is interleaving.
Spanner has this concept
called interleaving,
which is crucial for getting
optimal performance out
of your queries.
Interleaving is a
concept of having
parent-child relationships
between tables so
that data for child tables
are inserted in the same node
as the parent table.
This is essential because if
you have a has-many relation
and you try to get the related
rows from the children,
it's much more efficient to
look it up within the same node
rather than looking it up
across different nodes.
So in order to account
for this new concept,
we scan through all the existing
schemas we wrote for MySQL
and added definitions
for interleaving
for tables that had a
parent-child relationship.
At the same time, we
made sure all the indexes
that mimic the
relationship in MySQL
were removed, since they were
unnecessary when the tables are
interleaved.
Another thing we made
sure was that all
queries that scanned the
interleave children included
the parent IDs when
doing a lookup.
This was because omitting
it caused Spanner
to scan the entire database,
which degraded performance
tremendously.
To be absolutely sure that
the parent ID was included
in all the queries,
we added some code
that listened to
all the query events
and threw a warning when
the parent ID was omitted.
Next item on the list
is scale-in hiccups.
So in this game, we scale
in and out fairly often,
based on how much traffic
we're expecting for the day.
Scaling out is simple,
since all you have to do
is increase the number
of nodes in the UI
and wait a few minutes
for it to be deployed.
Scaling in, however,
was a bit trickier.
The actual task is the
same as scaling out,
but we noticed that when we
reduce the number of nodes
too aggressively, there was
a noticeable response delay.
These delays ranged
from a few milliseconds
up to maybe something
like 30 seconds.
Sometimes, this also
caused the servers
to choke due to too many
connections being open.
So we resolved this
by forcing Spanner
to time out in three
seconds and return
a response to the client,
which asks the client
to retry the request
after a few seconds.
In addition to that, we now
try to decrease the nodes
in small increments,
since the range of delay
seems to be proportional
to the number of nodes.
we decrease.
From what we can observe,
if we go easy and reduce
one node per five
minutes or so, we
manage to minimize the delay
enough that no retries occurred
on the client.
The next item is handling
bursts of access to shared data.
So the game has some
small sets of data, which
is shared across all users.
These are things
like item properties
and monster map coordinates.
We wanted to
replicate these data
so access to these data
could be distributed.
The way to do it in
Spanner was to add a column
with a shard number and
insert copies of the data
with different shard numbers.
Then, what you can do
is have the code select
one of the shards at random
and add that to the query
and that will
distribute the load.
We thought about
doing it this way,
but we figured it was too
difficult to implement
into the framework at the time.
So for shared data, we decided
to use a self-managed MySQL
instead, since it can replicate
and scale out easily if all you
have is a small set of data.
The last item on the list is
handling launch day traffic.
In order to talk
about this, I first
have to explain what a split is.
Internally, Spanner
divides your data
into chunks called splits,
where a split can move around
between servers.
And when there is
high load on a split,
it tries to slice it up
and add split boundaries
to distribute the load.
This works well in
normal scenarios
where there is a gradual
increase in users
with gradual growth on load.
But this was not
what we expected
to happen on launch day.
What we expected to
happen on launch day
was thousands of
users registering
in a span of a few seconds.
And we knew splitting
wasn't going
to be fast enough based
on numerous launch day
simulations we performed.
So in order to make this
work, we presplit the database
before the launch.
We called this process
warming up the database.
The way we warmed it
up was rather simple.
We just forced the
splits to trigger
by slowly adding
thousands of dummy users
until it split enough to
handle the launch day traffic.
After the split was complete,
we deleted the dummy users
since the split is retained even
after the users are deleted.
So the method was simple, but
there was one small caveat.
These splits were only sustained
if there was access to them.
Otherwise, these splits
start to merge again
after around 24 hours.
So we made sure to
do the warm-up 24
hours before the actual launch.
The warm-up was a tedious
and time-consuming task,
but we're glad we did it because
the launch was a great success
with zero problems.
Before I end, I just
wanted to show you
how our storage
architecture looks like
and briefly explain how
various services are used
in conjunction with Spanner.
All the storage we use
is lined up on the right.
Going from the top,
we have Spanner,
which holds all the
user data, as you know.
Our analytical data,
like user action logs,
is streamed to BigQuery,
since BigQuery works better
for scanning large sums of data.
Our master data, like monsters,
items, and location data,
is running on multiple
replicated MySQL servers,
where the load is distributed
using GKE service.
Then, we have
Memorystore, which is
used for temporary caching
of frequently accessed data
to ease the load
on other storages.
And I completely
forgot to add to this,
but we also use Elasticsearch
to store parts of our user data
so it can be used
to look up names
and other various attributes.
That's all from me today.
Thank you.
YUTTY KAWAHARA: Thank you, Taka.
Feel free to reach
out to us to find out
how Cloud Spanner can
[? erase ?] challenges
that you may be facing.
Visit URL to learn more.
Thank you for joining
today's session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]